vote buying has always been a calling
card of most corrupt governments in the
world from Latin America to Nigeria to
Zimbabwe it's pretty simple transaction
the government gives you cash and you
vote for them this is a familiar
territory in the third world and
speaking of the third world we have a
lot of these kinds of schemes in our
country student loan uh debt has been at
the center of many of these schemes and
the schemes are always incredibly stupid
so for example three years ago the
government put a pause on student loan
payments because of Co for some reason
Co meant that you shouldn't have to pay
your student debt
back um even though you still to pay all
of your other types of debt but student
debt was an exception and Biden after
taking office proceeded to extend the
pause and then extend it again and again
and again and again until just yesterday
on Sunday just 24 hours ago Joe Biden's
three-year quasi loan forgiveness
program came to an end all of a sudden
as of yesterday tens of millions of
people who took out massive loans to pay
for their college degrees whether it was
a degree in astrophysics or lgbtqia plus
studies or whatever it was had to start
once again
making payments on those degrees you
might remember that Joe Biden came out
with what was supposed to be a more
permanent loan forgiveness plan a few uh
a few weeks before the last midterm
election he said that the government
would permanently forgive quote unquote
up to $20,000 of federal student loan
debt for borrowers um a lot of Voters
believe that was true even though the
Biden Administration knew the plan was
never going to hold up in court he can't
just cancel debt he had no authority to
do it um and uh somebody in the end has
to pay for it that's the reality and in
this case predictably several States
went to Federal Court saying that they
have their own student loan programs
which were funded by tax dollars and
these states said that they stood to
lose a lot of that money if the Biden
administration's plan took effect as the
Supreme Court heard arguments on Joe
Biden's plan this year a swarm of blue
and purple-haired activists popped up in
Washington DC they made a series of
incoherent and frankly hilarious
arguments in favor of this student uh
loan forgiveness plan and here's just
one of them for example watch this I get
paid about $73,000 a year more than I
could have imagined as a young person I
was thrilled to start making a salary
after grad school I thought I'd be
rich and yet I am still drowning in debt
what's worse is it's considered less
than many people's debt only
$30,000 I'm lucky compared to a lot of
people to only have $30,000 of debt
which we have to admit is unacceptable
right right yes this is
absurd absurd yes now if you're paid
$73,000 a year that's a that's a good
salary in most of the country a lot of
people maintain households on far less
money than this graduate student makes
in fact she's making more than $10,000
above the median household income in
States like in States like Oklahoma and
Louisiana and other states but no sane
person would ever think that 73 Grand is
ever going to make them Rich unless you
live in the year 1847 or something 73
Grand does not equate to being wealthy
so why would anyone presume that $70,000
is somehow going to make them wealthy in
the year 2023 and perhaps most
disturbingly how did someone with this
level of financial illiteracy manage to
earn a graduate degree in the first
place the more you watch that video the
more depressing it gets uh here you have
a woman who earnestly believes that
going through the motions and and
racking up degrees should lead
inevitably to wealth because that's how
you get wealth you check a bunch of
boxes your whole life and you follow
orders you definitely don't innovate you
don't strike out on your own path you
don't do something different no you just
follow the program you go to the classes
you get the piece of paper that says
degree and Abracadabra wealth should
just appear this is the expectation and
shockingly for many people it has not
been met and she's not alone here's an
NBC News segment from a couple of days
ago featuring a salon owner who's really
upset that she'll that she still owes
$4,000 for her community college degree
and that now she's going to have to
start paying on it uh let's watch that
after 3 years of a pandemic pause
federal student loan repayments are set
to restart Sunday 3 months after the
Supreme Court struck down President
Biden's student loan forgiveness program
now many people are facing thousands of
dollars of debt and they say they still
have no way of paying it back NBC News
business and data reporter Brian chump
has
more Josie Bridges is a single mom
living paycheck to paycheck it's hard
enough dealing with Rising prices at the
store my student payments are sitting
right now at about $400 is what they're
expecting each month so I mean that's my
food budget right there the pandemic
freeze on student loan payments allowed
Josie to open up her own Salon in
Portland Oregon but with $4,000 in
outstanding debt from her community
college degree she says she simply won't
be able to make the payments once they
resume in October it's kind of out of my
hands at this point if I can't make it I
I can't make it it's a game changer the
the Biden administration's plan to
forgive up to $20,000 in student debt
would have wiped Josie's slate clean
instead a challenge from six Republican
states resulted in a Supreme Court
decision in June striking down the plan
after Josie had already put thousands of
dollars in investments into her Salon I
don't know what's going to happen in the
future and that's kind of
scary now you know I'm a big supporter
of small businesses I love it when
people go out and do their own thing
start their own businesses showing that
entrepreneurial spirit that once made
this country get great but the message
from this report seems to be that Josie
uh took major Financial risks on the
assumption that the government was just
going to wipe away her debt
unfortunately the magic debt forgiveness
Ferry never arrived and now she's stuck
paying back the money that she decided
to borrow in the first place so it's
hard to think of a better illustration
of the fact that this pause on student
loans was a self-defeating and
ridiculous and pointless
policy you know it's the quintessential
example of the government kicking the
can down the road which is the only
thing they ever do in response
predictably
enough many college grads Kick the Can
down the road also it's not like most of
them have spent the intervening years
saving money whether it's because of
Biden's terrible economy or inflation uh
or their own Reckless spending habits or
some combination of these factors many
of these college grads are now in the
same spot they were in when the pause
took effect if not an even worse spot
now the unpause button is pushed and
nothing was accomplished they're still
broke and they're desperate for more
handouts now it's clear that the left is
giving up their morals in any Common
Sense there's no better time than to
build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building habit of prayer can
help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you're
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
Hollow is the number one Christian
Prayer app in the US it's helped me
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you to download the app for free at
hello.com Walsh you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start check
out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year available on the Hallow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cavel
and even some worldclass athletes with
Hall you can customize a personal prayer
plan that works for you listen wherever
you are with downloadable offline
sessions using Hall to connect with
others who share your beliefs and values
can provide a sense of belonging support
and Foster a sense of community as well
ultimately we'll learn how we can become
better individuals in spite of today's
broken World As We strive to become more
like Christ in our daily lives through
prayer fasting and giving download
hallat hall.com
Walsh and get an exclusive 3 months free
that's 3 months absolutely free at
hall.com
Walsh social media right now is ripe
with videos from people panicking that
they have to pay back their loans again
many of them have advanced degrees some
of them have multiple Bachelor degrees
they've spent years and years and years
accumulating degrees and now the bill is
due and they're demanding that somebody
wave the magic wand and make it all go
away and of course what is the magic
wand well the magic wand is someone
else's bank account account because
there is no loan forgiveness there is
only loan
transfer and they want their loans
transferred from them to you as I've
argued for many years this idea is
flagrantly immoral it's
evil you know and it makes no sense if
it's somehow unjust to expect a college
graduate to pay his own loans then it is
self-evidently much more unjust to
expect someone else to pay his loans
like someone has to pay the debt and it
only makes sense that the guy who owns
the debt should pay
it everyone I think intuitively
understands this point when it comes to
most types of debt but college debt is
somehow treated as an
exception that's because the whole
scheme is just a form of upper class
welfare most student loan debt is held
by high wealth households more than 60%
of it is held by the rich in the upper
class people with graduate degrees
account for a half of all uh student
debt so these are for the most part
upper class people
and they were looking to get bailed out
and the bailout would inevitably come in
many cases from people who are who have
less money than they
do and while College grads try to reach
their hands into your pocket to take
your money to pay off their loans the
real villains in this story get off the
hook completely villains like the
university system itself which is
charging these exorbitant fees for what
often turns out to be a useless
education these universities operate
like hedge funds but they're taxed like
Charities they've been raising tuition
for decades with the help of federally
backed loans and when the students
default on those loans the university
owes nothing the student or the
taxpayers have to pay we've also been
letting employers off the hook as I
pointed out many times you know we
rarely blame them for needlessly
requiring a degree for jobs that can
just as easily be done by people without
them Corporate America and the education
system they have created this problem
yet they get none of the blame and the
working class is expected to pick up the
bill it's a Tale As Old As Time how many
entry level Consultants or government
bureaucrats really need a $200,000
bachelor's degree to work uh you know an
Excel spreadsheet and send some emails
it's
absurd and that last point is the thing
that I think is rarely mentioned in the
student debt conversation even though
it's the most important point of all as
we see all these college grads weeping
over their loan burden and it is indeed
an enormous burden we rarely State the
obvious which is that most of these
people never should have gone to college
to begin with we have people running
around with multiple degrees who never
needed
one there are people with master's
degrees who could have been just as
successful if not more successful with
with nothing but a high school
diploma now yes as already covered some
employers have created a sort of
artificial demand for a degree which
means that if you don't go to college
you will not be eligible for those jobs
even though you can actually you
actually are more than eligible like you
could do them but artificially they're
saying that you can't get in the door
because you don't have the G the the a
degree but there are many other career
paths that you can Venture down where
nobody cares if you have a degree I am
more financially successful than most
people with doctorates and my highest
level of formal education is 12th grade
so it is possible to find success with
without a college degree I know that
from experience now I'm not denying the
hurdles that you'll find in your path if
you decide to skip college and free
yourself from the scam I also know about
those hurdles from experience as well
but the only real long-term solution to
the student loan crisis the only way to
put an end to this lunacy the only path
out of this
Wilderness is for the majority of young
people to abandon the university system
entirely that is the only way and it's
the one thing that we don't talk about
when we have this conversation I've been
screaming it from the rooftops
forever but more people need to join in
the chorus or nothing's going to get
better because until that happens until
we see million ions of young people
going the just just bypassing the
university system completely they
graduate high school and they bypass the
system completely and they go out and
they live their lives and they get jobs
and they and they do something else
until that happens tuition will not go
down at all it's only going to go up
because there's no incentive for it to
go down the university why would they
why would they lower tuition they know
that you you know they know that parents
are going to shuffle their kids into the
colleges anyway they know that you're
going to you'll pay anything and so
they're going to keep raising the the
the
tuition there's no incentive and
Corporate America will continue
needlessly demanding degrees for jobs
that a well-trained monkey could perform
because again they have no incentive to
stop demanding it as long as we go along
with the program the program will not
change that's the simple reality if
people reject the program and they
reject the
programming the student debt crisis will
eventually become a moot point a thing
of the
past this is really the only path
forward and it's the only way that we
will really ever be able to say that the
student debt problem is cancelled hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promocode Walsh to
get two months free on all annual plans
see you there